salut vous avez vu en ce moment sur les
chaînes de piau dubaï de super connard
de pierre cros dab sol et de plein
d'autres que ça déconne à plein tube sur
youtube ou jeux de mots alors si vous
êtes abonnés à la chaîne pensez à
cliquer sur la petite cloche à côté de
l'abonnement pour activer les
notifications ça permettra que mes
nouvelles vidéos vous apparaissent
parfois en suggestion sinon vous
pourriez des ratés c'est pas tant pour
cette année d'ailleurs que pour l'année
prochaine mais ça on y reviendra
et aujourd'hui on va parler d'un cheval
mentalist génériques
nous sommes fin du 19e siècle
il ya un professeur de mathématiques qui
s'appelle willem van oosten qui a fait
toute sa vie qui a pris sa retraite en
1888 il s'installe à berlin
il veut se consacrer à ce qui le
passionne le plus en ce moment c'est la
théorie de l'évolution qu'on appellera
par la suite le darwinisme
il pense sincèrement que les animaux et
les êtres humains peuvent communiquer
entre eux et surtout que les animaux
sont très intelligents beaucoup plus que
ce qu'on pense et en même temps à
l'époque il n'avait pas les lolcats il
pouvait pas savoir le passionné de
darwinisme et de maths il commence à
enseigner les mathématiques à un chat à
un cheval et un ours normal j'en ai
c'est à dire quand et à la retraite tu
t'occupes pour faire court grosso modo
le chat au bout d'une heure il s'en fout
il se barre l'ours c'est pas terrible
par contre le cheval ça a l'air
intéressant et se dit ok je vais
enseigner les maths cas les chevaux ils
continuent à faire ça en stimulant ses
élèves on va dire à taper avec le sabot
pour donner les réponses aux opérations
ou aux questions qui leur pose et c'est
comme ça que willem von osten s'aperçoit
que hans est un petit surdoué hand c'est
un cheval russe qui l'a acquis
simplement il déchire il arrive des
soustractions la racine carrée
les additions les multiplications des
autos et c'est pour ça qu'en 1989 ten se
fait le plaisir de faire une petite
présentation publique de ses prouesses
avec ans du moins des prouesses du
cheval ou publiquement il va lui faire
faire des additions des soustractions il
aller plus loin que ça il fait aussi
lire l'heure il y aurait eu facebook à
l'époque ça faisait le buzz et c'est
cette même année que le psychologue
oscar function je vais jamais réussir à
prononcer son nom de famille
alors on va l'appeler oscars par son
prénom parce que c'est comme ça aussi
c'est beaucoup plus sympa je trouve donc
c'est en 1904 que oscar décide d'étudier
un petit peu en ce qui se fait appeler
ans le malin
c'est la première fois à ma connaissance
qu'un psychologue entament ce genre de
démarche
au début ça se passe très mal il faut
dire que van noten n'aime pas du tout la
démarche des oscars le psychologue se
fait même mort plusieurs fois par le
cheval mais après ils trouvent une
méthodologie donc au départ il essayait
juste de la pâte et avec de la
nourriture
et puis ils essaient des tests en fait
qu'ils sont pas forcément sur la pâte
quelque chose juste des tests normaux
mais plus rigoureux par exemple pour les
additions il écrit les chiffres sur des
cartes et il met les cartes au sol de
manière à ce que et le cheval et le
propriétaire du cheval vonlanthen est
lui même puisse voir les nombres les
chiffres il demande d'admission à 11 c
en stop avec son chapeau et répond il ya
98 % de réussite c'est quand même énorme
et la hausse car essayer une autre
méthode c'est à dire que les cartons ne
sont vus que par le cheval et pas par le
propriétaire du cheval par johnson et là
on tombe à 6 % de réussite seulement le
cheval se plante complètement dans le
même état d'esprit qu'en van oosten va à
l'oreille de hunt pour lui murmurer une
addition d'où le film l'homme qui
murmurait à l'oreille des chevaux quand
boonen stone souffle et l'addition à
l'oreille de son cheval le choix d'
avait un très fort taux de bonnes
réponses mais quand il ne lui souffle et
qu'un chiffre qui partait que oscar le
psychologue venait souffler le deuxième
chiffre et qui partait wantzenau
connaissent pas le deuxième chiffre et
oscar ne connaissait pas le premier il y
avait que le cheval qui connaissait les
deux et bella il se plante et ils se
gourent alors certaines personnes mais
dix ans tandis que c'était trafic et que
c'était truqué mais c'est pas ça c'est
encore plus intéressant que ça durant
des années 20 aux stones étaient
persuadés d'avoir réussi à communiquer
avec la race des équidés mais il avait
juste réussi à communiquer avec lui même
comment parce que le cheval était
mentaliste
et ouais c'est le premier il réagissait
simplement aux expressions faciales et
au langage corporel de son maître comme
il voulait la récompense il savait qu'il
voulait bien faire ils surveillaient
juste les expressions devant le stand
c'est à dire que si vansteene ne
connaissait pas la réponse à la question
qui lui était posée lui-même ne pouvait
pas savoir quelle était la réponse
puisque en fait c'est sur l'excitation
du visage de vonlanthen qui se basait
pour s'arrêter de taper par exemple
c'est énorme
il était tellement bon que même si
c'était pas bonne
qui lui posait la question il pouvait
réussir tout ce qui était important
c'était que la personne qui lui pose la
question connaissait elle même la
réponse ça a donné un nom à cet effet il
ya eu d'autres études de fait là dessus
dont une sur des rats et d'autres sur
des étudiants c'est pas la même chose
on a appelé ça l'effet clevers qui dit
que l'expérimentateur peut influencer
inconsciemment sans le vouloir le sujet
je vais vous mettre toutes mes sources
dans la description il y en a une autre
qui est intéressante qui mériterait même
une vidéo à part entière lisez si vous
avez le temps c'est l'expérience
pygmalion du psychologue robert
rosenthal de harvard qui a été aussi un
test sur l' influence de
l'expérimentateur sur un sujet mais là
sur des élèves sur des enfants et je
vous mettrais également un autre lien
sur guy wilks qui avait une hypothèse
également toujours sur le principe de
clever en ce que dans un interrogatoire
de police les policiers pouvaient aussi
influencé inconsciemment les victimes
les témoins les suspects mais sa
recherche est plus basé sur les témoins
et c'est ça qui est important
au final l'effet que les merengues c'est
ce qui a donné un petit peu cette norme
de faire des expériences en double
aveugle pour être sûr que
l'expérimentateur n'influence pas les
résultats
c'était la dernière vidéo de cette
semaine au bureau et tant mieux parce
que là on entend plein de travaux à côté
la semaine prochaine ce sera la vidéo à
la maison à l'ancienne la vidéo des
familles j'espère que cette vidéo qui
vous faisait découvrir un cheval mentale
et souza plus si c'est le cas n'oubliez
pas c'est hyper important de mettre un
pouce en l'air surtout dans ces temps
difficiles de youtube s'il ya d'autres
histoires de ce style dont vous voulez
que je parle n'hésitez pas à le mettre
dans les commentaires j'aimerais bien
avoir votre avis sur ce genre de format
peut-être que la prochaine j'aimerais
avoir une série comme ça où je vous fait
découvrir des choses toujours en lien
avec le mentalisme mais un peu plus
historique et un peu plus décalé je
voudrais votre avis si vous voulez bien
me le donne et fait très gentil avant la
fin de l'année j'ai également envie de
refaire une vidéo je mentalise quelqu'un
l'un d'entre vous l'une d'entre vous
donc je ferai la demande sur l'un des
réseaux sociaux vous avez tous les biens
dans la description de toutes manières
merci toujours d'être là toujours aussi
nombreux merci pour ceux qui sous titre
les vidéos merci pour ceux qui partagent
la vidéo vous êtes au top n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner si c'est pas déjà fait
et
le mental bogues et c'est toujours une
vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre
on approche du bout on va pas se mentir
donc rendez vous demain à 11 heures
ciao ciao ciao
[Musique]